>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Our closing speaker today first
came to the Library of Congress
from a series of internships with
the Hispanic Association of Colleges
and Universities while earning
a graduate degree in history
from San Francisco State University.
His time in our Digital
Preservation Outreach Division,
which eventually led
to full-time position,
was one of his inspirations
for going to library school.
Since then Thomas has
held digital scholarship
and digital humanities positions
at Michigan State University
and the University of
Illinois at Urbana-Champaign.
In April he was hired
as the Inaugural Humanities Data
Curator the UC Santa Barbara.
Sorry. I was that kid who always
got sick before the holiday,
and this is my holiday.
So when asked in a Library Journal
interview what a humanities data
curator does, he described one
aspect of his job as quote,
"Translating a researcher's
individual disciplinary competencies
so that they have purchase
in a digital environment
with materials they may not be
accustomed to working with."
This commitment to making data
research more accessible can be seen
in his recent launch of the
Source Caster with James Baker,
which helps you use the command line
to work through common challenges
that come up when working
with digital primary sources.
You should check it out.
It's really cool.
We've asked him to be our
closing keynote speaker today
to help make the future a
bit more accessible, too,
discussing where we go from here
to support data research
at our organizations.
Member of the Global Outlook Digital
Humanities Executive Council;
editor for DHCommons Journal and
dh+lib data praxis; author; speaker;
and teacher on humanities
data, data curation,
and data information
literacy, it is my pleasure
to welcome Thomas Padilla.
[ Applause ]
>> Thomas Padilla: Okay.
HDMI cable.
[Inaudible], okay.
Okay. So we're finally here.
I would just say at the
outset that I'm really honored
to be a part of this conversation.
It wasn't so long ago,
about seven years, actually,
that I got on a plane and flew to
DC with actually no job lined up,
no internship lined up --
purely based on wrangling one
of the manuscript curators
in the manuscript division to
give me a tour of the stacks.
And it was in October.
And I would like to say it
was like a beautiful fall day,
but it was actually
pouring and freezing.
And I soaked my shoes
all the way through.
But luckily, they still let
me into the back of the stack
to see George Washington's diary,
which in a way kind of
set me on this path.
So it makes it extra special
that I'm actually here today.
I'd like to start by
thanking Kate [inaudible]
and Jamie Mirez [assumed
spelling] and the rest of the team
of the Library of Congress
for putting on this event.
I know from my own time
here how much work goes
into putting together
something like this.
So thank you for doing what you do.
This has been an awesome
conversation,
and I think it was really
time for it to happen.
And it's excellent
to see the Library
of Congress taking a
leadership role in this space.
So today I'm going to speak
about three -- oh, yeah.
Okay.
[ Applause ]
Today I'm going to speak about
three conditions of possibility
that frame the way I look at the
collections as data conversation.
Those are agency, empowerment,
and ethics.
But first, I want to
start with a story.
Early last week I exited the
library at UC Santa Barbara,
put on my sunglasses, and
made my way across campus.
It was a typical day there; it's
like this basically every day.
It was 72 degrees,
sunny, no humidity.
I hope that doesn't
make you hate me.
The quarter's just starting,
so new students are out
and about learning their way.
You could say that it's a time of
uncertainty, and you could also say
that it's a time of possibility.
I took a deep breath and
I tried to clear my mind.
Lots of things compete for
attention, and to be honest,
it's not always clear
what really matters.
It can be difficult to hold
close to your heart the reason
of the things you do
and who you do them for.
One foot in front of the other,
I started to gain a
measure of clarity.
After near misses with
bikes, long boards,
bikes with people carrying
surf boards,
and enterprising Pokemon Go
players, I reached my destination.
It was a building distinguished
from the rest
in that it was taller,
it had a tower.
It's a university; we
have a lot of those.
I entered an elevator
to go into the tower.
The red digits flicked past
to signal the passing floors.
The doors opened and I
stepped toward a meeting
with the director of
a center on campus.
And I'm sure that there are folks in
our respective communities walking
to very similar meetings
as I'm speaking.
It was one of those first
conversations where the pressure
of possibility is everywhere.
Our conversation ran
a familiar course.
And despite a bit of
variation here and there,
the subtext buzzing below the
surface is often the same --
who are you, what do you do, and why
does it matter to me, to my people?
In these conversations I
often find myself in a sort
of intelligibility
and relevance bind.
It's like, "What is a
humanities data curator?
What are librarians for?
What is this digital
humanities thing?"
And as the conversation progressed,
there was a lot of academic, like,
hand gesturing around the table.
We're pretty good at
that in university land.
And after initial introductions
I had transitioned
to open the collections
as data topic --
something I'm really
passionate about --
when the director interrupted
me, took a measured breath,
looked me squarely in the eyes,
and asked pointedly, "Yes.
But Thomas, what are the stakes?"
It's an important thing
to think on, right?
What are the stakes?
Why are all of us here in this room?
I'm sure that many of our
institutions have collections
that are not too dissimilar
from these.
In this case it's a
collection of zines.
We could relatively easily
make available the catalog data
describing those collections
in the way
that the British Library has here.
Similarly, many of us probably have
works of art in our collections.
Maybe not all of us have Van Gogh's,
but surely we have works of art.
We could release individual
measurements of pixel values
in measuring things like
brightness, and hue, and saturation.
We could make that available.
Some of us may even have things in
our collections that could be used
to try and make some
sense of the Paris attacks
that occurred earlier this year.
And some of us have released
data related to those attacks,
in this case Nick [inaudible].
I think it was more than
10 million tweets captured
as the event was happening
and in the days that followed.
We could do all those things, right?
But it brings us back
to the original question:
What are the stakes?
Why are we doing it?
So for me, I learned
to identify the stakes
in architecture, which
seems fitting.
Like architects, we are builders.
We build infrastructure
in collections;
we support the formation of
community through these efforts.
The collections as data
conversation is an extension
of these commitments.
And though it is important
to emphasize in these efforts
that the conversation is not about
data for data's sake or computation
for computation's sake,
rather the work is intended
to build upon our commitments
to support nothing less
than the ability to
experience life is worth living.
This is not a new role for us.
We have not been without
imperfection in this role,
as has been indicated by
some of the presenters today.
But collections as data
provides an opportunity
to continue to learn to do better.
And so the conditions
of possibility for me,
our agency, empowerment, and ethics.
In my perspective, the first
condition in the collections
as data conversation
centers on agency.
To see collections as data is
to step toward claiming agency,
to extend individual
capacity to act.
I acknowledge the chance of initial
alienation around this framing.
Data, after all, are not likely
to be what the majority choose
as a first conceptual
frame for interacting
with a book, a song, or an image.
In the face of the familiar, data
may seem a cold path to discovery.
Yet data are vibrant
with possibility.
They are the product of
human design and worldview.
Reclamation of agency is learning
how to recognize, interpret,
and act upon the facets of
human intention in the data.
By figuring collections as data,
we seek to make these facets known
and usable to our communities.
There is more than one path to
enabling the capacity to act
with data, but I'll talk about
one in the interest of the time.
This is a path that is generally
functional in orientation
and depends on the
notion of affordance;
it's a pragmatic approach.
Basically I approach a
seemingly familiar object
and ask what functions it affords
to help resolve a question.
I then transition to consider what
additional functions it affords
if I engage it as data.
Something comprised of vast
numerical difference often bound
in codified systems
that speak to each other
across great distances
of space and time.
As this path is traversed, I
think it's really helpful to think
on Martin Mueller's reminder
that every surrogate has
its own query potential,
which for some purposes may
exceed that of the original.
Now, as a physical object a
newspaper readily affords certain
types of functions -- you can
pick it up, you can fold it,
you can unfold it, I mean,
you can orient yourself
to a relatively significant amount
of heterogeneous content
in a condensed space.
Once you digitize it -- does
this project look familiar?
Once you digitize it, the
collection has become data.
In the Library of Congress
Chronicling America Project,
we see collections as data being
leveraged to enhance the ability
to act upon it at micro
and macroscopic levels.
Shifting between these
scales, we witness a paradigm
that extends familiar
expectations for working
with the source objects --
the ability to browse,
to search, and to read.
Go back. While the
platform is committed
to supporting these
familiar functions,
the designers of Chronicling America
in a nod toward the data-centric
possibilities provisioned an API
and multiple methods to get
bulk access to the data.
And these preparations have since
supported a number of projects
that explore the collection
to its fullest data extent.
This was covered a bit earlier.
I'm going to talk about it
in a little bit more detail.
Spurred by the recent
NEH-funded contest, you know,
this is one project -- I
think it won first prize --
by Lincoln Mullen.
He leveraged machine learning to
identify over 866,000 quotations
and verbal allusions from the Bible
across 10.7 million pages
of historical newspaper.
Amidst nearly 56 billion words
Mullen not only identify the
phenomena he was seeking but
further augmented the data
by creating new linkages between
it indicating not only when
and where Bible verses
occurred, but also discerning
and subsequently explicitly
structuring the data
so that they indicate how often
verses tended to occur together.
This act sheds a more complex
view on use of the Bible
to support the formation
of our varied imagined
communities over time.
Of course, our collections
are not limited
to surrogates of physical objects.
Increasingly, we collect
so-called born digital data.
Web archive collections are
significant efforts here
at the Library of Congress,
the Internet Archive,
and throughout the world --
institutions large and small.
A key component of the data
orientation with respect
to these collections is learning how
to recognize what their
nature affords
for supporting exploration
of questions.
It will continue to be the case
that we will have users that want
to interact with these archives, as
a user may have interacted with them
at the time of their
creation in a web browser,
on a mobile device, and so forth.
Yet, if we peel back the layer
to engage the underlying,
less visible structures organizing
the representation we see
on the screen, it becomes
possible to ask more questions.
Consider Ian Milligan's work
on Canadian political
parties and interest groups.
In this network visualization,
Milligan has drawn connections
between all links that crisscross
Canadian political parties
and interest group websites.
From this vantage point,
Milligan gains a sense of typology
in the data -- a multidimensional
view of connectivity
that may have not been readily
apparent and/or intelligible
without an awareness of
the possibility latent
in the data sitting below
the surface of the familiar.
This push towards reaching
past our familiar orientation
to digital environments
is what the collections
as data conversation is all about.
The deeper we go down this path,
the better we serve
our community's ability
to peel back the layers covering
seemingly mundane interactions
in everyday life in order to
recover an ability to act.
Empowerment.
In order to do the
work that lies ahead,
we will need to be empowered
to think differently.
When I say we, I am
referring to the builders
at cultural heritage
institutions large and small.
When I say that we must be
empowered, I refer to the concept
in its truest sense as a move
towards self-actualization.
I'll speak now from the perspective
of libraries in particular
since that is the community I
have the most familiarity with.
There is a base claim to
universality often touted
in libraries -- universal
collections with impartial aims,
services with a universal scope.
In this manner libraries are figured
like transaction-driven
benevolent black boxes.
But seriously, I would say
down with the black box.
Libraries are people.
Individual hands, hopes, and dreams
build the collections we use.
Let's acknowledge that,
celebrate it,
and give credit where credit is due.
Collections as data
provide an opportunity.
Who designed the schema?
Who did the transcription?
Who decided why the acquisition
should be made and for whom?
Why did a certain normalization
occur?
This is about recognizing the
labor and the intellectual value
of librarian contributions
to crafting the materials
with which a wide array
of communities gain a sense
of meaning in the world.
It is also about surfacing the
design decisions underlying these
collections in order to give
them their fullest integrity,
so that they can actually be used
to substantiate claims
that are based on them.
There are many directions
the collections
as data project could go.
In almost any direction we will
bump into preexisting norms
for going about this work.
And there will undoubtedly
be expectations couched
in terms of scalability.
Here are the chickens, if
anyone was following on Twitter.
There's actually only two slides
with chickens, so I apologize
if the expectations were raised.
But the scalability
question, that framing.
To be honest, I'm a little
bit tired of scalability.
It's like a chicken or the egg
debate where someone keep insisting
that chickens sprang from an
[inaudible] chicken forehead
and won't consider the
possibility of the egg,
that both could actually
happen in parallel,
that they might actually need
to happen that way in order
to push the conversation
forward in this space.
Sidebar, I want to thank Katy
[inaudible] and Trevor [inaudible]
who in their piece against cleaning
from their curating the menus
project, they introduced me
to Ana [inaudible], who I'm
just going to quote here
on the next three slides because
she really captures this notion
of scalability that
I'm trying to get at.
Highly recommend her piece as well.
So when small projects become
big without changing the nature
of the project, we call that
design feature scalability.
Now, scalability is possible only
if project elements do not form
transformative relationships
that might change the project.
And here's the kicker:
But transformative
relationships are the medium
for the emergence of diversity.
Tying it all together from what I
would consider a classic piece --
although it's probably only
four or five years old --
it's a talk that Bethany Nowviskie
gave, "A Skunk in the Library."
You know, kind of writing on digital
library work -- or speaking on it --
she had said, "If you want
unusual results, you can't expect
that they will come from
playing by the usual rules."
A couple of issues typically
arise as librarians aim
to extend their commitments in
the collections as data space.
First, it is often expected that new
ground is broken, yet the potential
of the work is mitigated
from the outset by attempting
to predicate effort on
a scalability paradigm.
Scalability cannot be the sole
precondition of possibility
in the collections as data space.
In order for diverse
solutions to occur,
we must learn to embrace
experimentation that accommodates
and even embraces the value of
failure as equally as success.
Some may say that the
ability to engage in the span
of outcomes constitutes a
luxury, a privileged position.
I would say to look to liberal
arts colleges, oftentimes dwarfed
by their R1 research university's
peers throughout the country.
They're doing some of the most
interesting work in this space
and with vastly limited
resources comparatively.
The second issue impeding
forward progress relates to time.
As previously mentioned,
as often the case
that there is an expectation,
the new ground is broken
but little is done administratively
to free up individual time
to contribute to new projects.
I find more often than not that
personal interest or excitement --
what you might call the
preconditions of the empowerment --
are not the barrier to doing
collections as data work.
Rather, it's simply a
question of whose lack
of resolution can often be
traced to administrative mishmash
between goals and reality.
Simply put, let's free people up to
empower themselves in their work,
whether that's collections as data
work or some other new initiative.
Now, I've long admired the work
that Cooper Hewitt has done
with collections as data.
They're enthusiastic and very
public about their experiments.
They actually have a menu
on their website called Toys
with an experiment section.
There are currently four
experiments listed there.
They're all disabled.
Does this mean they've failed?
Could we consider the possibility
that they may have been meant
to fail, that they may actually
be a good thing, these failures?
As we move out of the experimental
section of the Toys menu
to the Exploration menu, we are
presented with a dizzying array
of ways to engage the collection.
Search by color?
You got it.
Search by concordance?
Why not? I don't know with 100%
certainty, but I bet that more
than one of these features
started in the mind of someone
who felt empowered to explore.
That exploration was run
as an experiment, disabled,
and then walked into the
primary collection interface.
On this slide we witness one
of these experiments in action.
What we are seeing is
a really novel solution
to addressing a particularly
challenging problem.
Essentially they're trying to deal
with differing scale between objects
in a collection and the challenge
of how to generate thumbnails
that convey an equivalent amount
of information to the user.
Right? So if you took a picture of
a chair from a distance of five feet
and maybe a pencil from, you
know, eight inches above,
how do you create equivalent
thumbnails
that help a user make a decision?
Right? So one of the
things that they did
in the labs is they
wrote a Python script
to generate Shannon entropy values
for each image in order to inform
which part of the image
would actually be cropped
so they would convey
the most information.
The British Library Labs has
been doing fantastic work
in this space for years now.
Folks like Norah McGregor, Mia
Ridge, formerly James Baker.
I feel like they've kind
of been eating everyone's
lunch a little bit,
especially in the national library
space -- sorry, Library of Congress.
[ Laughter ]
But yeah, they're an
enterprising group.
They engage in teaching digital
scholarship within their institution
and they work toward
releasing a whole slough
of different types of
collections as data.
You may have heard of their
pioneering work automatically
extracting a million
images from historical texts
and making them available via
Flickr under a CC0 license.
Subsequently they have encouraged a
number of competitions for working
with the collections that
they release as data.
These efforts are not
purely about publicity;
they provide opportunities to
refine the way that we prepare
and provide access to
collections and can lead
to concrete reciprocal benefits
from outside our institutions.
For example, in this case Mario
Klingemann's experimentation
with machine learning and
semiautomated image classification
to generate additional metadata
for the Flickr release and also
to enable subsetting by really sort
of interesting features like all
of a sudden it becomes possible to
subset the collection by portraits.
It's kind of cool.
I'm not sure exactly what
the application would be,
but it's kind of a cool
functionality to enable.
There are a number of
libraries in North America
that have been working
in this space as well.
I'm formerly of Michigan
State University.
For those of you not working in the
Big Ten or fans of college football,
that's the green helmet
up there on the left.
While our collections across the
board here differed in scope,
we all shared in common a desire to
explore releasing our collections
as data in order to encourage
additional types of use.
The process in my case -- excuse
me -- was fairly straightforward:
Identifying existing
digital special collections,
evaluate the possibilities latent in
the data -- are they unstructured,
are they structured; what
is the quality of the OCR;
has it been transcribed; has
it been hand-transcribed;
how representative is the
data given its relationship
to the totality of the collection?
The next step was to
create derivatives
that served anticipated use.
So out with the JPEG
thumbnails, in with the PDF's,
the TI-encoded files, the
plain text derivatives.
Wrap all of the above
in new documentation
that is geared toward
supporting computational use.
Now, subsequently this data was used
to support digital
humanities pedagogy.
It became a test set in a text
analysis program and was sought
after to support a computational
analysis of ingredient usage
in cooking throughout
American history.
Had we not treated this collection
as data and promoted it as such,
it's not likely that it would
have seen these types of use.
Now, work of this kind
only becomes possible
when individual people feel
empowered to pursue their passions,
to self-actualize through them.
The cost of that self-actualization
is time and the confidence
to pursue projects whether
they succeed or fail.
Really, failure should
be a goal, I think.
That said, embracing failure
doesn't mean doing our work
without attention to ethics.
We must commit to transparency,
inclusivity,
and respect in the
work that lies ahead.
A number of ethical considerations
are raised in this space --
some of these are new,
others are familiar
but possibly more complex
in light of the medium.
The first issue relates to
transparency in the process
of collection building: How were the
data processed; what was left in,
what was left out, why; how
representative is the data;
what bias does our organization
of the data reflect;
can we admit a bias?
I think for a number of reasons
the data-driven journalism has some
qualities that we can learn from
as we consider these questions.
Recently journalists at Buzzfeed
supplemented an article --
"New American Slavery,"
shown here --
with a blog post that links
to data methods, analysis,
and code used to produce the work.
We see that the level of
transparency is quite granular.
The writers go down to the
level of individual claims
in their narrative text with
links to the IPython notebook
that contains the code
that generated the data
to support that particular claim.
As I cast my eye over this approach,
I wonder what it can teach us
in libraries as we work to
provide collections as data.
Will our user expect similar levels
of transparency in the documentation
of computational processes and
analytic decisions that were made
to generate the collections
that we provide access to?
They may. Transparency in this
vein may actually be a precondition
of viable use.
As collections as data are
developed, we cannot lose sight
of interests beyond
North American borders.
We must have an inclusive vision.
Global Outlook Digital Humanities,
affectionately referred to as GODH,
reminds us of this pointedly:
There's a wider world
to engage with; we
should think deeply
about how we can best interact.
Part of that consideration
is linguistic.
speaks to questioning assumptions
of normative access to
computational infrastructure.
Through GODH's experiments
with minimal computing,
we can discern a model for
encouraging participation
in these collections as data
conversation that is more expansive
than it would be otherwise.
Across the board, we require
acts of bravery large and small
to make our collections
as open as possible.
Few things make the light of
curiosity die more quickly
in someone's eyes when
they shift to the words
"rights assessment is
your responsibility."
I've experienced this myself.
This is something I've
witnessed personally
from primary school teachers when
I worked in education outreach here
at the Library of Congress
to researchers interested
in large-scale text analysis
in the various universities
that I've worked at.
NYPL, I would argue, is a
shining light in this space
that I'm very grateful for.
More open collections
equal more access,
which in turn equal a more
inclusive range of use.
Now, this is important: Collections
as data represent lived experience
and we should respect that.
Traces of human activity are
not butterflies to be collected,
cataloged, and pinned in 21st
century cabinets of curiosity.
Documenting the now focuses
on capturing a liminal
form of data or tweets.
While the technical
development is impressive,
it also presents an approach
that models how we might engage
in collections as data activity
that is expressly predicated
on sustained attempts to ground the
act of collection in community need.
Documenting the now approaches
this angle of work in a number
of different ways, but
I'm particularly intrigued
by Burgess Jules' [assumed
spelling] attempt to map precedent
in arcable practice codified in
the deed of gift to gain a measure
of purchase over the
challenges that lay ahead,
particularly as they pertain
to structuring agreements
between data producers
and data collectors.
I hope we see more efforts
like this in this space.
A contract, after all, is about
agreeing on the terms of engagement.
It's about mutual respect.
In her interview with
the LA Review of Books,
Jessica Marie Johnson hits
upon one of the key failings
of our collections --
their inclusivity and
their representativeness,
she like many others have
by necessity sought meaning
in the fragments and absences
in arcable holdings that testify
to practices of systematic bias
whose net effect is nothing less
than an attempt at
historical erasure.
Sometimes it is the case that the
histories are buried beneath the
homogenized approach to
representing our collections.
Seeing collection as data offers an
opportunity to surface difference
in the historical record.
In the case of the real
face of white Australia,
Tim Sherratt leveraged a
facial detection script
to automatically extract faces from
a wide range of historical documents
and place those front and
center to give people primacy.
In doing so, Sherratt utilized
a data-oriented approach
to humanize the data
and surface a story
that might have been otherwise told.
As we transition our historical
sources to meet the collections
as data mark, we must be conscious
of the extent to which the bulk
of the digitized historical record
privileges white, English language,
predominantly Western history.
This is a legacy born of early
20th Century microfilm collection
development policies.
Subsequently, many digital projects
have worked from these data sources,
which biases said projects toward
reinforcing a less pluralistic view
of the world.
Presently we have an opportunity
to create collections as data
that better support the
ability to craft narratives
that reflect a greater
diversity of lived realities.
Jared Drake reminds us that we
all are complicit in the creation
of collections that
reinforce inequity.
In order to improve we
must face that reality,
really look at it,
and aim to do better.
As I have mentioned
throughout this talk,
collections as data provides
an opportunity to do better.
There is some initial
concerted effort seeking
to improve our work in this space.
The Digital Library Federation
Cultural Assessment Group is one
promising start.
It's early on, but they're
expressly geared toward identifying
and questioning the
underlying biases
that are driving digital
library collection development.
You may have noticed throughout
this talk that I didn't talk much
about infrastructure with
any degree of specificity
or really anything
particularly technical in nature.
It wasn't my goal to do so.
That said, I wish it went
without saying, but I feel I need
to say it anyways, any
infrastructure we develop
to push the collections as data
conversation forward must take place
in an environment that recognizes
and works against historic
and contemporary hostility
toward women, people of color,
and other underrepresented groups.
And we come full circle.
There's an incredible amount
of opportunity that lies ahead.
If we stay true to supporting
the agency of our communities
as they seek to make meaning from
the data, if we empower ourselves
to be inspired by our own
experiments with data,
and if we are guided by an ethics
that focuses on transparency,
inclusivity, and respect, I
truly believe that we are heading
in a promising direction -- a
direction whose path charts a course
to nothing less than
supporting life is worth living.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.